[MUSIC PLAYING]
PUNEITH KAUL: I would
like to introduce Robbie.
Robbie's a tech lead on the
Google Cloud AI Platform,
and one of the founding
members of the team.
He built the first [INAUDIBLE]
back-end of Cloud Machine
Learning Engine service,
and currently he's
focused on ML
prediction and related
services, likes to work
on other areas of machine
learning and Cloud Platform.
Before his time at
Google, he studied
statistical natural
language processing,
culminating in a dissertation
in the area of machine learning
known as active learning.
Robbie, in his
outside work time,
likes to spend
time with his kids.
He has five lovely
kids, and he's
very passionate about that.
I've known Robbie for
the last 2 and 1/2 years,
and you couldn't have been in
more better hands than Robbie.
So Robbie, please take it away.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBBIE HAERTEL: All right.
Thanks for that
introduction, Puneith.
My name's Robbie
Haertel, like he said,
and I'm really
excited to be here.
Just by way of--
I know you're going to fill
out-- we keep saying, hey,
we want feedback.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Couple of questions
along that line.
Just informally, how many
here would consider their role
to be a data scientist?
Their primary role
at their company.
That's a good number,
but might not even
be half, or just over half.
What about data engineer?
Do you consider that?
Some of the same hands went up.
If you'd told me before, I
would've chosen the other one,
right?
You got some data engineers.
What about just like
software engineer?
So that's a good lot of people.
So those that are
software engineers,
are you here because like
machine learning is maybe
a hobby or something
that you're looking
to get into so you can go
down that path in your career?
Is that why you're here?
Anyone here for other reasons?
Just because of pizza?
Is someone here for the pizza?
That's why I came.
They said, you can
have free pizza,
but you got to give a talk.
I said, worth it!
So here we are.
AUDIENCE: I'm doing a startup.
ROBBIE HAERTEL: You're
doing a startup?
And so you're here to figure
out what's on offer for that,
right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ROBBIE HAERTEL: Very cool.
AUDIENCE: And can
you show us how
to implement a Google Duplex?
[LAUGHTER]
ROBBIE HAERTEL: Well,
speaking of that,
let's set expectations.
So as was mentioned, I'm one
of the leads on the Cloud AI
Platform team, so our job is to
provide a platform for you guys
to do machine learning.
So if you came here
thinking that I'm
going to show you how to train
really fancy models to get
the highest accuracy, and here's
the tricks you do in sklearn,
and here's the hyper parameters
you tweak in XGBoost,
you're probably not
at the right talk.
I hope you'll stay, anyways.
Hope you'll stay, anyways.
But what I'm here to show
you is what the Cloud
AI-- are you seeing like all
my emails come up and stuff?
What the Cloud AI Platform can
do for you folks in your roles,
either as a hobbyist,
trying to learn,
as a data scientist trying
to get your job done,
as a startup.
I think Cloud Off has a lot
of benefits for startups,
actually.
How many here would
consider yourself
to be working for a startup?
I'll raise my hand.
You know, like what?
Google's not a startup.
But you know,
Cloud AI Platform--
this is a relatively new area.
I know that they have existed.
Google, actually-- I worked
for an internship at Google
for what was known as
the Prediction API.
We recently turned that down.
But that was one of
the first public cloud,
machine learning offerings.
And I was actually sad to
see it turned down, not just
because I worked on it.
I think it was actually ahead
of its time, quite a bit.
And it's still probably
ahead of its time.
We still probably
have a few more years
to go until we can really
realize the promise of here's
a CSV, here's your
trained model, go for it.
But anyways, thank you
for entertaining that.
Thank you, Puneith,
for setting this up.
I'd like to think that I was
capable of doing that myself.
As I begin here, a special
thanks to the people that
helped me with the slides
and the demos that are here.
I couldn't have put it together
without the following people--
Noah Negrey, Younghee
Kwon, Bhupesh Chandra,
Kathy Tang-- who's in
the audience right now--
and the rest of the
Cloud AI Platform team.
So I really appreciate
all the help
they gave me with
the demos and stuff.
And then of course,
special thanks
to those that
organized this meeting,
and special thanks to all
of you that are attending.
Back to the topic of
providing feedback.
You know, I think
Puneith mentioned
that Cloud AI Platform
started about three years ago.
So we do have some experience
with working with users,
with getting their
needs and requirements
and trying to understand those.
That said, we believe that we're
at the very beginning stages,
and that there's so much more
that we can and should do.
And in fact, we
believe that we're
in a hypothesis-testing phase.
And what we would
like to do is--
we've made certain assumptions.
And as we go through
this talk with you,
if you notice some assumptions
that we've made that are wrong,
I'd like to come up to one of
us afterwards and say, hey, what
about this?
Did you think of this way?
Or hey, you know what?
Our requirements are actually
a little bit different.
Have you thought
about providing this?
We'd really like to
understand those things
because if we build a
platform that you can't use,
I've just wasted the last
three years of my life.
And I'd like to think that I was
trying to do something useful.
And even if I failed
the last three years,
I'd like to continue on this
path of building something
that you guys can use.
So the topic of the talk,
as has been mentioned, is--
well, I kind of changed
the topic slightly.
But it's Production scikit-learn
and XGBoost, specifically
in the cloud.
We'll talk just briefly about
off-the-cloud use cases.
But you guys, most of you
here, about half of you
said you're data scientists.
Some of you are hobbyists
or did ML in grad school,
so you're very
familiar with this.
Is my mic still on?
I feel like it went off.
We're still good?
OK.
You guys could probably
preach to me about this.
This is my view.
I won't spend a
lot of time on it
because I believe you're
all familiar with it.
The model development cycle
is more or less like this.
You have a problem to solve.
You collect data that will
help you solve that problem.
You almost always have
to clean the data.
Then you decide what
model you want to use.
If it's a image classification
or some sort of perception
problem, audio, maybe some text,
you might use a neural network.
But if it's a clickthrough
rate prediction,
you might use
logistic regression.
If it's structured
learning, maybe you'll
use gradient-boosted decision
tree, something to that effect.
Those of you that
have been in the field
long enough kind of already
know this model works well
with this type of problem.
Then you need me to go
through and take this raw data
that you've cleaned, and
analyzed, and collected,
and you need to do some
feature engineering.
Especially if it's logistic
regression or some sort
of linear model, you're gonna
need possibly quantization,
one-hot encoding.
You're going to need to do
feature crosses, all sorts
of logs of certain
types of features,
all those types of things.
And once you've done that,
you can now take your data set
and you can train a model.
And most models have
hyper-parameters.
And your goal is
not to get a model,
it's to get the best possible
model given the model
selection and the feature set.
So you'll train that.
You'll do some
hyper-parameter tuning,
and at the end of the
day, you have a model.
And you'll take that model and
you'll analyze the results.
Hey, what's this
model doing well?
Where does it succeed?
Where does it fail?
And what can I do to get
a better model out of it?
And depending on
what the errors are
that you see, you may decide,
ah, I didn't have enough data.
Or my data wasn't clean enough.
Or I need to add more features
or different features.
Or maybe I need a different
model class altogether.
Anyway, you go through this
feature engineering cycle
or model development
cycle, and then what?
You end up with a model, right?
You have a model
laying on your desk.
Now what?
So training a model is
simply a means to an end.
It's not an end
in and of itself.
We train models because we want
to do something interesting.
The problem is-- let
me see how many of you
can relate to this tweet.
"The story of enterprise Machine
Learning-- 'It took me 3 weeks
to develop the model."
That's not too bad.
That's probably about right.
She's probably skipping how long
it took to get the data ready,
but we'll spot her that one.
"'It's been over 11 months, and
it's still not deployed.'" How
many of you guys
can relate to this?
Maybe instead of 11
months, it's six months.
Maybe it's 20 months.
But at any rate, ignoring the
data part-- because we all
know that that's hard,
very hard oftentimes--
but getting the
model into production
actually takes often much
longer than training the model.
And how many of you think
that the fun part is getting
a model into production?
My guess is that the
reason you're here
is because the fun part is
making the model, right?
This is a screenshot and
it's very hard to see,
of a Jupyter notebook.
What if you could take your code
that you ran to train the model
and click a button,
and you're serving
your model in production?
Well I'm here to tell you,
obviously, that you can.
And yes, I'm running a Jupyter
notebook on a Pixelbook,
so that's a plug for those that
want to run Chromebooks here.
The running example
that I'm going
to use this to train
a clickthrough model.
Sorry, a clickthrough
rate prediction model.
And I'm going to use XGBoost
as the underlying learner,
and I'm going to use
some sklearn pipelines.
Again, if you came to see some
secret sauce on how to do this,
you're going to be sorely,
sorely disappointed
because you guys are going
to come back and say,
why didn't you do this?
Why didn't you do that?
Why didn't you do this?
And in fact, I hope you will
because these examples are
going to be in GitHub.
Go ahead and augment them
to your heart's desire
and we'll accept reasonable
submissions in that sense.
The training data that we're
using is the Criteo sample.
I think it's 11
gigabytes, and it's
seven days worth of clickthrough
data that's publicly available.
It was used in a
Kaggle challenge.
So if you look at
the code here, we're
just doing very standard stuff.
I tried to keep the
example overly simple
for the sake of illustration.
We parse a few
arguments, and just
because they'll show up again--
I don't want to spend
too much time here--
base directory is just sort of
so you know where the logs are,
and so you know where to
export the model and that type
of thing.
And then the event
date is-- what
I'm going to do
is, given a date,
I'm going to look
back for seven days,
use the past seven days
to train a new model,
and then go from there.
OK?
This here is like
cheating, I guess.
Max samples is 7000.
Recall that I'm on a Pixelbook.
I'm not going to
be able to train
on seven days worth
of data, and I'm
going to emphasize that point
on purpose a little bit later.
This little beautiful
block of code
is just reading in the data.
And you you're like, why
are you using pandas?
I won't get into those
details, but there is a reason.
It's to get the right
data format so we
can use a dict vectorizer.
Here's the XGBoost regressor.
I'm training a XGBoost
model, obviously.
It's kind of like logistic
regression, I suppose.
And then we create an
sklearn pipeline where
we have a dictionary
vectorizer, which
will turn the
categorical features,
do the one-hot encoding for us.
I call pipeline.fit, we cross
our fingers that it works,
and we won't necessarily
wait for it to finish,
but it won't take very
long because I used so
little data and all that stuff.
It says it's done.
So with, essentially,
one line of code, you
save the model out.
I'm sure you guys are
all familiar with how
to pickle a model.
And then this command
here-- gsutil--
it's just a file
copy command that you
use to go to the cloud, because
if you try to use cp, obviously
it won't know how to
get it to the cloud.
So we save the model.
We copied it to the cloud.
Now we need to actually
deploy the model
as a service on the cloud.
What we're going to do,
with these two commands
here, is that's going to
create a REST API for you
that you can then send
prediction requests to.
And it does all
the load balancing,
it does all the auto-scaling,
it has the web server,
authentication, authorization,
prediction, et cetera.
We'll talk more about
that, although I
might condense that part
of the slides, anyways,
in a few minutes.
So this first line
here, we have a notion
in the current service called
a model, which is essentially
a collection of versions.
We'll see how this, in
the context of training
new models every day, allows
you to keep various versions
and switch between them.
Like I'm serving
yesterday's model,
and I now need to serve today's
model, but for the time being,
think of it as a container.
We create this model.
If I do it again,
I'll get an error
because they have to be unique,
so I'm not going to run it.
Now this mess that is
cURL will not be there
in about a week or two.
We just got the
command line tool
updated to accept framework as
a command, and it wasn't there.
So it's essentially very similar
to the model's create command,
but it's versions create.
So we're saying, create
a version of this model.
And since I bumped up the
version to v4, when I run this,
it's actually
going to the cloud.
And you can imagine,
because it's doing
all the things I talked about--
load balancing, web servers,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
it does take a little while.
But ours is actually very fast.
It takes about-- I think the
median time is 90 seconds.
Your very first model may
have a little bit more in it--
time, and be more on the
order of five minutes,
but it takes about
a minute and a half.
So while we're doing that, let's
switch back to the slide deck.
Now I know we have to do
a context switch for those
that are engineers.
The software engineers-- you
understand that reference.
But the question, why is
production such a long pole?
Remember, that was
one of the pain points
that we're addressing
in this talk,
is that it's hard to get
models to production.
I wanted to open that
question up to you guys.
What are some of
the reasons that it
takes so long for models
to get into production
in your experience?
Getting the data?
Well, what about once you
have the model, though?
So you've got the data,
you train the model.
All you really want is
to show impact, right?
To get a better performance
review scores or something
like that.
Or validation?
Well, that's a good
point, actually.
Yeah.
And I don't talk too much--
I hint at that on
one of the slides,
but you're not going
to put something
to production that's junky.
Bring down your system.
Any other reasons?
AUDIENCE: Performance
evaluation.
ROBBIE HAERTEL: Performance
evaluation, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: You said also you want
to be sure that you can roll
back if something went wrong.
ROBBIE HAERTEL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You have to
prepare for that as well.
ROBBIE HAERTEL: Yeah.
You've got to be able
to do a safe roll back.
Very good.
Back here?
AUDIENCE: Managing the
infrastructure [INAUDIBLE]..
ROBBIE HAERTEL: Yeah.
How many of you consider
your favorite thing to do
is to manage infrastructure?
That's why I have
a job here, right?
Doing this.
Exactly.
I may be the only
one in the room.
Here's a few other things.
You guys said some
really great things.
I didn't even think
very hard about this,
and these are the ones that
came off the tip of my tongue,
or fingers.
You need to get approvals.
You need to do
capacity planning.
Some people-- I actually
had a conversation,
I can't recall
right now who it is,
but you have to
convert your model
from one format
to another format,
and then do validation on
it, that type of thing.
There's some
technical challenges.
Somebody mentioned that just
creating a serving system
is a very complex stack.
You have your load balancing.
You have your web server.
You have authentication.
You have authorization.
Oftentimes you have a cache.
You have logging agents.
You have monitoring agents.
They all have to work together.
One thing is to get
all of those up.
Another thing is to keep
all of them up, right?
Because if any one of
those pieces goes down,
it's your pager that goes off.
If you're the
production engineer.
And you probably don't
want that to happen.
And certainly, those of you
that are data scientists,
even if you're
capable of doing this,
that's probably the last thing
on earth you'd want to do.
Otherwise, you would be a
production engineer and not
a data scientist.
So here's what Cloud ML
Engine Prediction offers.
It's click-to-deploy.
It has horizontal auto-scaling,
so as you send out
more traffic, it scales up.
You send out less
traffic, it scales down.
And it's serverless, so
it scales all the way down
to zero, which is really
fantastic when, say, you're
a startup, and your
traffic patterns
are very sparse at
the beginning phases.
You get some traffic
and you're happy.
It scales down really low
and you're not so happy.
Or very spiky traffic.
We scale up very quickly.
Our servers are able to scale
very world-class, really.
We give you encryption,
authentication, authorization,
logging, monitoring.
You can organize your
models with labels.
You can do versioning rollouts
and things of that nature.
So let us go back here.
Because it's a
Jupyter notebook, you
don't get the nice
spinny indicator.
I don't have a nice
extension to do that.
But we can go ahead and just
start sending traffic to it.
So you can see that
this piece of code
really boils down to these four
lines, which is essentially one
line that I broke up because
a really long line is
hard to read.
Or two lines, really.
You create a connection to the
service, and you call execute,
and you pass it the data.
This example-- it's
not clear from the way
I've organized the
Jupyter notebook,
but it's literally the
same data structure we
used for the local prediction.
OK.
That's going to get
translated, obviously,
to JSON because we've set
up a REST API to do that.
And you can see, if I'm lucky,
in the previous round run,
they were both the same.
I'll keep my fingers
crossed with the live demo.
And I get a warning
about credentials,
but otherwise, we
get the same value.
I'm comparing the
local prediction--
pipeline.predict.
Recall that I have
an sklearn pipeline,
and I'm then calling
Cloud Prediction,
and grabbing that
out of the cloud.
Very fast, low-latency
response times.
Well, it happened
to still be up,
but if it had
scaled down to zero,
that request would
have taken a little bit
longer to bring up the servers.
But it's very fast.
OK.
So let's move on to the
next section of the talk.
So that's prediction.
Like I said, the premise
was, you have a model.
We combined sklearn features
like pipelines and XGBoost
as the underlying model.
You can use any of the models
that sklearn has to offer,
any of the transforms
that sklearn has to offer.
Essentially a click of a button.
And we're working on a GUI--
I think it's close to being
implemented-- where it's
literally a click of a button.
You point to the
model and you're off
serving in production
at production scale.
And you don't wear
the pager, I do.
So let's talk a little
bit about MLOps.
This asterisk ops,
if you will, is sort
of a buzzword in the industry.
We've got DevOps
You've got DataOps.
You've got PSYOPs.
You've got-- I don't
know what other ops.
So of course there's MLOps,
because why not, right?
What do we mean by that, though?
I like this diagram.
If I hadn't stolen it from
a paper from some folks that
work here at Google,
I probably would
have chosen a little
different boxes,
but I think it serves to
illustrate the point very, very
well about what MLOps are.
If I can direct your attention
to that teeny, teeny, teeny,
teeny box in the center of the
screen, that's the ML code.
That's the code that you guys
write as part of your job
to get a model running.
All of the other
stuff is what it
takes to serve,
and not just serve,
but to train and use ML
in a production scenario.
Sure, if you're
just fooling around,
like for a research
paper, and you
got to get a more accurate
model than the last guy that
published a paper
in this domain,
you don't need all this stuff.
You can do to do it
in a Jupyter notebook.
Go use Colab, or Kaggle Kernels,
or your favorite Jupyter
notebook and get it done.
If you're going to do
something in production,
there's a lot of work
that goes into it.
You guys are probably very
familiar with the data
collection phase, maybe
configuration as well.
Obviously, feature extraction
in a production system
that has to be running--
it's like a service that's
running on a continual basis.
We have your serving
infrastructure,
which we already went into
slightly more details about how
complex that can be.
You've got to have resources
monitoring, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah.
There's a lot that goes
into serving in production.
When you define the term MLOps--
when you define the
term DevOps, it's
merging software
development processes
with software operation.
So I actually think that
that definition does not
hold up for MLOps.
Why?
Because I feel like we
should be taking the ops out
of ML, so that our jobs in
serving production systems
is more like the small
black box, and less
like everything around it.
Let's let the
infrastructure-- let's
let somebody else have the job.
Let's let somebody else carry
the pager, type of thing.
And so that's really our goal.
Let me give you an
overview of what I think
the steps should be for MLOps--
with most of the ops
taken out of the MLOps.
The first step is to
develop your model.
I would hope that that
would be 99% of your time.
You'd spend the three weeks to
get the best darned model you
can out of your
data, and then you're
ready to use it in production.
Of course, this is
the nice GUI that I
said that's not quite there yet,
but it will be in a few weeks.
You click a few buttons
and you deploy it.
You can go-- and I
forgot to do this.
If we have a chance, we
can go back and look at it.
But we have monitoring and
logging for all those models
that we just deployed.
Single-click, and
it's all there.
So you're looking at it.
You're looking at your
latencies and you say, oh, wait.
Why is my latency so high?
And then you say, oh.
I get it.
I didn't have enough
cores, or I didn't
have enough nodes, to handle
the spikes that we had.
You make a few tweaks,
you click a button,
and you're off and going.
And ideally, ideally you
don't even have to do this,
but the reality is we're
not quite there yet,
so you have to do a
little bit of tweaking.
But you can even do it yourself.
That's how easy it is.
And that's how I think
MLOps should be done.
So why cloud?
Now I probably should've
asked a question.
I don't know how many of
you-- well, let's just do it.
How many of your
companies currently use
the cloud for any of their ML?
We have a few, but not many.
And we find that to be true.
I'm not here to
sell you on cloud.
It might sound like it, and
I apologize if that's true.
Obviously that's what
I do for a living,
but let's just have an
open conversation here.
The cloud isn't
necessarily for everybody.
I had a few conversations
offline with some people.
But here's where it does shine,
and if you fit these needs,
you ought to consider it.
We have world-class networking
and infrastructure here
at Google.
We really pride
ourselves on that.
So you can count on lower
latencies, faster startup times
and things than you'd get by
rolling your own solutions.
Elasticity and scaling--
those are buzzwords as well,
but if you think about
it, if you purchase
a cluster of computers
to put in your own office
or your own data center,
you have a fixed cost.
And if you use more
than that, you're
going to get really
bad latencies
when you're serving because
you don't have enough capacity.
If you use less
than that, you're
wasting money on servers that
are sitting idle, or worse,
using power.
And in the cloud, you're
paying for what you use.
You scale up, you
pay for what you use.
You scale down and
you're not using any,
you don't pay for anything.
High availability.
Google prides itself on
this, and part of that's
due to the next line,
which is Google SREs.
SRE means site
reliability engineer.
You may have heard of this.
Google hires the
very best engineers
that know how to run and
maintain production systems.
And they helped
design the system so
that there are fewer
outages to begin with,
and when there are outages,
it's their pager that goes off.
And they know how to
respond and quickly mitigate
any problems that are there.
And that's part of the
reason why Google Cloud has
high availability
for its services
is because of these folks here.
Speed of deployment.
You saw, in 90 seconds,
we went from a model
that I trained on my
laptop to one that was
serving at production grade.
And then you'll
probably see this line--
maybe I overemphasized
this, but I really
believe that the total cost of
ownership and paying for what
you use is a real
benefit of the cloud.
So what if you're not ready yet?
There's many reasons why.
Maybe these use cases
doesn't fit your scenario.
Maybe your company's really slow
at adopting things like cloud
or other technologies.
Or maybe you guys are just
onboarding but you still
have a transition time.
I'd like to refer
you to Kubeflow,
which is built by our team--
the Cloud AI Platform--
and what it is--
I like to call it
the anaconda of ML.
So it's a bunch of packages that
bring you ML, make ML very easy
to do on Kubernetes.
So if you guys are already
using Kubernetes or thinking
about Kubernetes,
where you can run it
on your laptop with Minikube,
on-premise if you private
cloud or on-prem servers.
You can run it on the cloud.
Amazon just released
their Kubernetes.
Microsoft has their
Kubernetes, but obviously I
want you to use Google's
Kubernetes engine.
And there's the hybrid
case where maybe you
do have a data center
and it's at capacity,
but when it goes
over capacity you
can spill over to the cloud.
And of course, the
cloud ML engine
that I'm focusing on more
or less today that we have,
I'd like to think of cloud ML
engine as managed Kubeflow.
So if you don't want to
manage this stuff yourself,
you can pay for the
managed service.
All right.
So I focused a
lot on prediction,
but the MLOps stuff is
a lot more than just
prediction, as we
saw in the diagram.
So now I want to talk a little
bit about non-prediction cases.
And there's a lot
I can say, and I
can tell you, just as a teaser,
expect a lot from Google
in the coming months, in a
lot of really cool stuff,
and that's all I can say.
But when might you want
to train in the cloud?
These may seem
obvious, but let's take
a second to talk about them.
In the cloud you can get
really large machine types.
How many of you guys have 96
cores sitting under your desk?
If you do, I want your machine.
I can't remember
what we cap out at,
but I think it's somewhere
like a terabyte of RAM.
We have machines that
have that much memory.
And you know what I found?
I actually had an intern
do this last summer.
I said, hey.
Go grab the Criteo data set.
Go get as much RAM as you need.
Get a VM with as
much RAM as you need
and train it, and
see what happens.
It took three hours to train.
You needed a lot of RAM,
hundreds of gigabytes, I think.
Took three hours to
train and he was done.
He didn't have to go figure out
how to do distributed training.
He just had to pay for three
hours of a server, a fairly
reasonable price
with that much RAM,
shut it down when
he was done, and he
had a really great
model because it
was trained on all that data.
Number of cores.
Imagine you're doing a
hyper-parameter sweep, grid
search, or something
like that, and you
want to do it in
parallel, but you
don't want to set
up a SPARC cluster,
or you don't want to
maintain any of that.
Go get a machine with 96 cores.
You can run 96--
well, it depends on how many
cores each job's running,
but you can do a lot of stuff
in parallel with 96 cores.
Of course, you don't
want to go get a VM
and do all your work on
that because you'd be
paying for it the whole time.
It's expensive.
But this is what the
cloud brings to you.
I talked about
distributed training.
It is non-trivial.
If anybody's had
to set up XGBoost
to do parallel training
on SPARC, you can do it.
There's some sample code
online to try and do it,
but it's actually non-trivial.
And we don't yet support
XGBoost distributed training,
but for TensorFlow,
it's very simple
to do distributed training.
If you're using
tf.estimator, you literally
have no code to change.
You submit it to the
cloud and it scales up
to the number of servers
you tell it to scale up to.
And hopefully one day
we can bring something
like that to XGBoost.
We have a
hyper-parameter service
called HyperTune, which
is available for XGBoost
and scikit-learn models.
And it gives you
much better results
than doing a grid
search or random search.
It's state-of-the-art
algorithms,
so you'll get best-in-class
performance there,
and it's all in parallel.
You don't have to wait.
So I talked to a
researcher here at Google
and he says what he
does is he plays around
during the day on
small data sets,
gets things how he likes them,
sends off a job at night,
comes back in the
morning and checks
on how well his model did.
Keeps his fingers crossed that
there was no errors halfway
through, right?
Can anybody relate to that?
I know that's what I
did during my PhD, too.
Repeatability.
So what I mean by this is--
there's more examples, but
the best example of this
is with continuous training.
So we're talking about
training a clickthrough rate
model where you get new
logs, and tons of them,
every single day.
And every single day you're
going to train another model.
And so you're going
to use the same code,
and you're going to use
it every single day,
or actually a lot of people
train like every hour,
so they're training
very frequently.
You're not going to want to
go to your Jupyter notebook
and hit a button at
4:00 PM every day
to train another model.
This is a repeatable
process that
needs to be productionized.
It needs to be robust.
And so the cloud is
really great for this.
And in fact, if you're
taking advantage
of those large machines
and those large cores,
it sends off a job.
It uses all those things
for a short period of time.
It shuts it down, and you
only pay for that time
that you're doing it.
So let's come back
here to see what that
might look like in the cloud.
So there is a price
to pay when you're
switching from your local
machine to the cloud.
You do need to package
up your code in a way
that the service can understand.
And there are multiple
ways to do that.
We'll be supporting
containers, which
is becoming an
industry-standard way to do it.
For now, we use Python packages.
So you just run
python setup.py sdist.
You see the second
command then uploads it
to a bucket in the cloud.
And I think that's finished.
And then I'll go
ahead and hit Enter,
and then you can see right
here all I'm doing is saying,
submit a training job called
CTR, for clickthrough rate,
with the time stamp
so it's unique.
I'm saying that
it's trainer.train.
This package is what
we just uploaded.
The runtime version tells
us which version of--
now I wish that was
more obvious that this
was like scikit-learn
whatever version,
but this does translate
into scikit-learn version.
This is Cloud ML Engine's
runtime version 1.8.
We're going to do
it in US central.
It's with this project, and a
few command-line parameters.
So just since I
forgot to say this--
this train.py is that exact
code we saw at the beginning.
The only thing is you
would probably take off
that max sample
lines that I had,
because my Pixelbook
couldn't handle it,
and I won't admit how long
it took me to figure out
that's what was
crashing on my notebook
because it didn't tell me.
And you know, you might
change the max depth,
or the number of
estimators to be what
you would have in production.
This is your actual
production code.
So you make a few tweaks.
You send it off to the cloud.
You can see that
the job was queued.
Again, we don't have a
first-class integration,
so we have to go over
here to our list of jobs.
And let's see.
That one-- you see
the spinny thing
means it's still
spinning up the machines.
Our prediction service
actually spins up
the machines very, very fast.
The training takes
a little bit longer.
I think if it's a
single-machine job,
it's usually around
one or two minutes.
So we can go to this job
here, take a look at the logs.
Nothing super interesting,
just to show you
that there's this integration
here with the logs
if I'm lucky enough
to get it to come up.
So you can see that
all the output's
captured in the logs in
case you need to go back
and figure out
something that's wrong
or something that's right.
And you can see that the
job completed successfully.
So that's how you
send off a single job.
But the use case that
I was talking about
is really about productionizing
this and doing it
on a daily basis.
How many of you are familiar
with Airflow, by chance?
A couple of you are?
Probably the data
engineers, I think.
I mentioned to
somebody before we
started I'd hint at a
little bit of pipeline here.
So what Airflow is-- and there's
lots of orchestration systems,
but it allows you to
chain together various
processes that you can then
do on a repeated basis.
In this case, on a daily basis.
You can see that right here.
And I'll get into what
this actually means,
but you can see that
every day for the last two
weeks, this code that we
just submitted to the service
to run to train a model has
run on the previous seven
days worth of data,
produced a model,
and then pushed that
model to serving.
So let's go ahead and you can
see that in a graph view here.
Very, very simple DAG.
I did that for the
sake of this demo.
It just does training and create
version, but some of you guys
have already pointed out an
obvious problem with that.
If something went
wrong during training
and I pushed it to production,
I'd be in a world of hurt.
Could even get fired for that.
So what you would normally
do, and it's actually not
that difficult.
You can put another mode in
the graph that runs evaluation,
and another node
in the graph that
checks that the
quality of that model
is better than the previous,
or the model that's currently
serving, before you push
it, and then go ahead
and push it to serving.
But for simplicity's sake,
I just trained and pushed.
And you can look at-- the
code to do that is actually
very, very reasonable here.
Again, you have the preliminary,
which binary do I use,
et cetera.
These DAG args are just
necessary for Airflow to work.
A little bit of overhead.
Copy and paste is what I
like to think of it as.
And then here's where you say,
hey, with DAG-- in other words,
with my pipeline that
I'm trying to define--
you have this training
op which looks
very close to the gcloud
operation, but in Python code.
It says hey, use this
binary for training.
And then you have the
create version op,
which again looks like the
gcloud option for pushing
a version.
So I mean I don't know how
many lines of code that is,
but the core of this is, what?
20 lines of code, maybe?
And we've defined this
pipeline that we're
able to run in the cloud on
a daily basis that pushes
the models to production.
Let's see if I have this.
So you can see, here's
the model ctrdaily.
Remember how I said, model's
like a container for versions?
And here are all the
versions of that model that
got pushed on a daily basis.
Now also on a
production system, you'd
probably be
garbage-collecting these
so you don't have so
many laying around.
You can see that this
is the default one,
so if I send traffic
to this model,
it's going to actually
go to that version.
You'd want to update
that on a daily basis,
at least after
you'd validated it.
So yeah.
Any questions?
I forgot to say this.
It was kind of difficult with
all the interruptions we had.
My preference was going to
be to have questions in-line,
but I'm almost at the
end of my talk now.
But any questions about these
pipelines or the training?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The logging
that you showed--
ROBBIE HAERTEL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that something
that spit out of the cloud
box itself, or is
that something that
if I had logging in my code,
that I can spit out to?
ROBBIE HAERTEL: Yep.
Yeah.
So if you do your print
statements-- your logging.info
statements, if your
Python programmer--
those things show up here.
And I think it tells
you which one's which.
The standard error
shows up unfortunately,
as orange warning signs.
There's nothing to
be worried about.
That's just XGBoost telling
us that it's doing work.
Any other questions?
So this is really
the end of my talk.
Just to summarize
in a few points,
productionization is hard.
Cloud is easy.
And you pay for what
you use on the cloud.
All right.
And a few teasers,
I guess, before we
move to see if there's
any other questions
about the entirety of the talk.
But our team is working
on increased focus
on reducing MLOps.
So we saw probably 10
boxes on that page,
and I addressed a few of them,
like the continuous training
case and the serving case.
But there's actually a
lot more boxes on there,
and you better
believe that we're
spending time making this easier
and easier as time goes on.
Increased cost
efficiencies work.
That's a continuous focus
for us because we're
able to amortize the cost
of the infrastructure
across everybody.
So we're actually able
to get you lower costs
than you might on your own.
And then we're also
working to allow
data scientists like yourself
and even data engineers,
as well, to share their
reusable work with others.
We're working on
ways to do that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]